[Music]
foreign
as a true legend in the makeup world who
sold her company for millions and the
author of several best-selling books
Bobby Brown didn't have a lot to prove
but she's back in a big way with Jones
Road the new makeup company she founded
with her husband Meg Oliver spoke with
both of them in their first TV interview
and joins us now good morning Meg Dana
good morning to you Jones Road is named
after a street the couple passed in the
Hamptons and liked how it sounded and
customers like what it represents as
evidence by its loyal following
so I looked at my head a product and I
said oh my God this is a friggin Miracle
this is how legendary Bobby Brown
relaunched her career social media I
always love learning new makeup
techniques warming up in your fingers
gently Pat it so that's all you need hi
what's your name in January 2022 nearly
15 months after the makeup Mogul started
her new company Jones Road will you tell
my husband I don't want diamonds I want
this her son Cody head of marketing
pushed her to make a tick tock and he
said all right mom go and he pressed the
button hey guys it's Bobby here I'm new
to tick tock tell me what you want to
see from me it and two others were game
changers attracting more than 300
million views and quadrupling sales for
the startup we got bombarded and I was
so surprised because most of the women
said oh my God I'm so glad you're here
I'm 50 what do I do I'm 60 what do I do
I'm 40 it was shocking Bobby has been
teaching four generations of women what
to do when it comes to her Infamous no
makeup makeup look when did you know you
wanted to get into makeup when I was a
kid deciding what college to go to my
mother asked me what I would do if I
could do anything in the world and I
said I'd love to do makeup after
graduating with a degree in theatrical
makeup she started in the world of high
fashion in 1987 she fell in love with
her soul mate real estate developer
Stephen plofker I remember I came home
from dinner and I was up all night
staring at the ceiling and I called my
dad I said I just met the man I'm going
to marry yeah I just knew it you just
knew I just knew it how are you feeling
when you first met Bobby a little
overwhelmed I mean something definitely
out of the normal was happening they
were married within six months a few
years later in 1991 the couple launched
the brand Bobby Brown a palette of nude
lipsticks that quickly shot her name to
fame within four years Estee Lauder
bought the company for a reported 75
million dollars but Bobby retained
creative control you signed a 25-year
non-compete Clause any regrets about
that I have no regrets because there's
no point in having regrets because what
are you going to do with it and honestly
we the company wouldn't have grown as
big I mean I could say that I am a
founder of a billion dollar brand which
it was when I left how was it waiting
out your non-compete it was hard I went
and got a charm with the date that my
non-compete was up you know to someone
that doesn't have hobbies and isn't used
to quiet time or reading in a chair it
was tough so I did a lot of things my
makeup philosophy is that I like it to
be quick I like it to be natural during
that time she shot a master class became
a certified health coach
and renovated a mansion with Stephen
into a boutique hotel the George in
Montclair New Jersey it was a labor of
love but man that was intense and every
room is every room was different the
place was a total redo and what I didn't
say he's not just the brains of the
operation he is the most creative able
to see things where other people can't
and he figures out how to get it done
but this is supposed to be about you
they can edit
on October 26 2020 the couple launched
Jones Road against the odds it was a
week before the presidential election in
the middle of the pandemic in the middle
of social unrest and all of my big
powerful friends in PR said don't do it
I engaged my neighbor to do the pr we
got great press and it was Off to the
Races Off to the Races with instant hits
like Miracle Ball a multitasking skin
enhancer that sold out in weeks how did
you come up with Miracle Ball
it was a mistake it was yeah I had asked
a lab to do something and it came and it
was not what I wanted I'm like that's
not what I wanted but then I dip my
finger in it
and like I always do I went like this
and put on my face and I'm like oh my
God
I love this from Miracle bomb and what
the foundation to face pencils Jones
Road is a collection of clean beauty
products designed to be simple and easy
to master these are called just the SEC
okay because that's how long it takes
okay perfect to put it on and when it
comes to her own self-care it's no
surprise she also keeps it simple how do
you take care of yourself I don't inject
anything in myself and I'm learning to
you know find peace with the lines in my
face I just take good care of myself and
I try to be positive and upbeat parents
to Three Sons the couple's family has
recently expanded and I have two
daughter-in-laws and a granddaughter oh
my God she's amazing she's like
delicious recently Bobby posted a love
letter to them I happen to love the
girls and you know I'm trying really
hard not to piss them off you did your
one daughter-in-law's makeup for her
wife I did both of their makeups for the
wedding probably probably the scariest
makeup jobs I've ever done that's
amazing besides Michelle Obama that was
scary too but yeah high pressure that
was high pressure but you know the
daughter-in-law's
that was I wanted to please them this is
good for an overall tint a highlight a
blush it's that kindness that resonates
on social media making her still seem
like the girl next door eager to help
you look and feel better at 65 what
would you tell Bobby who was in her 30s
oh my God I would say you're not even
going to believe what's going to happen
but I would say just get ready and be
open and you just don't know what's
coming your way
Jones Road is expanding with a third
store opening in East Hampton one before
Memorial Day and into other markets
across the country in the next two years
I was talking to her last night and she
was saying you know this is my second
time around and I'm overwhelmed at the
response to everything and she wants to
credit her husband who's been there the
whole way but really doesn't get a lot
of recognition not that he wants it but
credit to her though taking the chance
and the rest I love her I want to just
hang out with her by the way too I just
want to hang out with her so down to
earth they're lovely and they're just
good for her thanks Mike